ah yeah I almost died hi everybody how
you doing good to see you again if you
didn't know we just had a charity
livestream over I think some of it got
in my mouth if you didn't know we had a
charity livestream over the weekend for
Best Friends Animal Society and it went
fantastically I haven't done a charity
livestream especially on my own in a
long time and we raised a ton of money
for the Animal Society I don't know
exactly how much we sold about three
thousand seven hundred shirts just in
the amnesia grunt shirts and then we
sold an unknown number of the other
stuff my farm
I dropped my flour oh it's got yeah it's
got gas on it and the amount those
donated directly to Best Friends Animal
Society I don't exactly know I know that
I donated six thousand dollars but I'll
have to talk with them to find out
exactly how much you guys donated on top
of that either way it was an incredibly
successful charity campaign you guys did
amazing and I'm so happy that we were
able to do it again and I can't wait to
do it in the future because we got other
special items that I know you guys are
want time to get some new Fleur
I don't want disgusting used FLARP here
not doing it yeah you like that
everybody yeah is that gonna plug I get
flarm anuria by the way I went to this
store again and I picked up some strange
chemical substances that I'm gonna be
playing with fretless Latta rocket also
I picked up this father at the door haha
I really like it Disney print that yeah
also I mentioned on Twitter but I'll say
it again here I like to sing poop songs
and that means I take popular songs and
I replace important lyrics with the word
poop can you feel the poop tonight
Hey let it go let it prove can't hold it
back anymore why you gotta be so poop
don't you know humph roofie to do that
the next time you're listening to the
radio just sing long and Replace
important words with the word poop it'll
be the most fun you've ever had driving
in traffic
Derek cars that are next to you also
while you're singing it it'll be really
fun
storia my poop I give her poop offender
poop until she's poop inside the story
of my poop had this orange FLARP
everywhere and my tiara won't stay on
what is life why is life so hard I know
that some people are gonna kill me if I
don't do this I'm gonna mix the silly
sludge hook sludgy
I'm gonna mix the silly sludge ah uh uh
uh Oh God flubber no we put on my
protective crown to keep me from not
doing this stuff and let's get the floor
it's like this on of Satan's boogers
mixing it all all them two ready I hope
this doesn't react chemically key and
just explode in front of my face you
know these things that five-year-olds
can play list uh uh uh get more of the
floor pin there you know I bought all
this floor this is what I do that's what
I do with my life I go out and buy I
thought my mouse goobie I'm gonna do it
again
it's princess Lorber oh my malice thingy
again ah the glasses huh alright so
anyways on a serious note I just wanted
to thank you guys so much for supporting
the charity livestream there were so
many people there there was over 20,000
people in the stream at all times I
think we peaked around 28,000 people it
was just an all-around fun time
especially to be able to talk with you
guys again
I mean we had so much fun playing games
and directly interacting with you which
is something that I haven't had in a
long time and I just wanted to tell you
guys how proud I am of what you managed
to do um this community that we have
together is so important to me now I
feel like me not doing these often
enough kind of loses the sense of
community that we've built I mean you
guys are such a beacon of hope in the
YouTube like world and that may seem
cliche or sound really silly to say but
it's true because I said this in the
livestream but I'll say it again here
when I talk to other youtubers about
their communities and especially like
their comment sections and their fans
you know they'll say sometimes like oh I
saw out of hand these days with so many
people it's just so weird and vitriolic
and they're all so mean together but
I've never felt that from you guys you
know I've always felt that you guys have
been a shining example of what people
can do when they're united to a common
goal and the fact that we can do these
charity livestreams and we can have so
much fun together and yet at the same
time still be serious and remember what
the important things about this is you
know that's something that a lot of
people don't get in something that I'm
honored that you guys are so mature and
ready to accept you guys are willing to
take these charity efforts to another
level you guys are willing to unite and
be this you know example of what other
youtubers communities should aspire to
you have inspired so much out of the
YouTube community
that you just spread good wherever you
go and that's something that I'm very
proud of what you guys have done and
what we've managed to accomplish
together and that's something that I
want to nurture going into the future
and I may be silly you know with my poop
songs and my silly crap and whatever I
do but it that's just part of the fun
that we have you know we can be serious
and have fun at the same time and that's
something that I've always appreciated
because I get to do what makes me laugh
you know I get to make videos that make
me laugh and you guys enjoy it too and
also we're able to take this platform
that we've built from just a few
thousand people to over two million
people almost 3 million people together
all in one place just having fun and
remembering the important things that we
do that's amazing and that's something
that I'm eternally grateful for and the
fact that you guys rally behind my
causes and they're not just my consoles
there are our causes and the fact that
we're able to change the world for the
better everyday it's just it's
absolutely amazing
so just remember guys know I I may
inspire some of you to do good but you
guys all together are an inspiration for
everyone around us you know it's not
lost on the rest of the people in the
YouTube community that we together have
done amazing things and we have inspired
others to continue to do great things
we're not the first to do charity but we
as a whole are so collectively united in
this cause that other people are
incredibly inspired to do these amazing
things to enjoin us in these costs
so thank you guys so much for being
together and being here for me when we
do these charity livestreams and I want
to do so many more in the future and I
hope you guys will join me as we
continue to move into the future and
doing whatever cool things that we're
going to do I'm glad to know that you've
always got my back so thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye